a $500,000 one coin package for anyone
who can corroborate little hoodies STD
just want to make that clear yeah anyone
who can corroborate or offer more
information on little hoodies as to me
you know yeah the story I have is that
he actually likes to pee his pants a lot
okay he doesn't like to use a bathroom
that's what I heard everyone the high
house was like a little hottie heeda
he doesn't like use the bathroom it's
really weird and so he pees his pants so
much in the same underwear that he just
he just films tik toks in the bathroom
but he doesn't use it to write us
exactly he's got a weird thing about it
you know yeah he's that good the
bathrooms not for pissing yeah it's for
dancing I don't get it we're dancing and
shooting yeah and so he got a he's not
for pissing and pooping he got the first
male UTI from peeing his pants so much
you know which led to an STD supposedly
mmm you know wewe can I have anyone
information you know any adults who can
corroborate a story about a 16 year old
peeing his pants as a member of the hive
house you know one trillion dollar one
coin package available to you so it's
just like it's too much for me you know
it's too much like after the trip club
news of last week or the week before
drawn over the drip house the drip has
chlamydia however I don't even know I
had to block it out of my memory because
it was too it was too traumatic for me
laughter laughter you know so I tweeted
the morning after I seen all this
footage said about the hype house on TMZ
I just tweeted wait little hottie has an
STD like just trying to be funny and
then I felt bad I didn't want to pile it
on with someone reply to that and said
the clap house and I don't know why
that's it's the same thing is that we're
talking about that about the drip house
yeah but does everyone oh dude twelve
teenagers with the clap
dancing on camera just untreated is this
so funny
oh my god
we all have chlamydia renegade renegade
anyway good I'm just no nothing it's
just like you know after the trip always
came out saying that you know the the
drip shack wasn't wasn't sticking
together like as a group like that
already hurt me so much as a consumer of
their content they when all this stuff
started happening with little hoodie and
with you know Charlie it just couldn't
couldn't get into it yeah it's too much
for me
bro the UH like what like what am I
having like some worried someone peed
their pants and like that that's
definitely everybody it was I see people
tweeting about it I'm laughing like
aren't these kids like like five like I
said Maj them all like literally
five-year-olds just peeing and [ __ ]
all over that house like crying nothing
in there's a big deal it's like yeah a
little hoodie someone didn't mix his
formula and then you know they fed the
the the Gerber to the other babies so
now everyone's upset like I don't baby
drama this is baby drama drama one of
them was using the other ones diaper and
I didn't piss on it and we just got big
use the other ones you know pacifier and
just all [ __ ] up it's just classic
baby drama why don't you read that why
don't you read the bro oh my god he's a
[ __ ] diary entry that he that he
posted did he post this publicly yeah he
tweeted this and I thought this was the
the funniest way to to take the heat off
him cuz basically what he got he got
outed let me stop pretending he got
outed for cheating on Charlie right okay
like that is that right like I think
that that's my understanding is that he
I'm not sure but that I guess that would
make sense
he like kissed somebody I don't know man
you know which is whatever did obvious
obviously yeah I think what do you
[ __ ] expect this 18 year old to do
bro I think if a girl kisses a little
hoodie they're technically a lesbian
like one choker away from being a woman
you know then yeah yeah he's a teen yeah
right he's a teen okay so we can we can
we could joke about him oh he's he's
he's of age we can definitely clown him
all right I'm just I'm just saying like
[ __ ] these people who the [ __ ] is
at TMZ as an adult writing an article
about an 18 year old kissing another
person other than their girlfriend
everyone 18 year old does that it's
pathetic every but everybody does that
yeah I I kiss my mom my grandma what's
the big deal exactly
so yeah I don't want to be an eighteen
year old that's not Mormon that's
faithful to their girlfriend he [ __ ]
he goes since all my drama has to be put
on the internet for the world to judge
me let's lay out everyone else's oh wait
wait
you know be funny not an M right now bro
read this though you said bro first of
all hilarious they just take the stand
and just snitch on everybody
yeah Wow Wow
Anthony got with Cynthia and dude like
and bro it's so funny it's like when you
read this to Everett to all of us we're
gonna listen this and go what the [ __ ]
happened and yeah but to the hype house
fans each one of these is like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah no it's like I don't this
just like I said this looks like
someone's diary entry yeah from this
this looks like when you find a box of
your old [ __ ] when you were like 5 and
you open it up and it's like mommy went
to the store today I had fun with
Kristen like you know Jake is my best
friend by far except for Edie said that
to him did not use the toy and I said
okay it's reason your huh that's what
this reads like Anthony I'm saying is
there any funny way we can read this oh
yeah like like a British accent or
something
it's been here a week after we woke up
on tour Jayden actively tried to hook up
with Dixie at our house and on the 4th
of July in front of me while she was
dating Griffin Griffin cheated on Dixie
with Taylor's ex Kaylin and vices ex
Ellie
ooh Jayden and Josh cheated emili´s
amounts of times on meds and Nessa for
the past few months
Quixote on Olivia own star runner no
this is this is the best part right here
so the only person has a right to be
upset with me it's Charlie and I'm sorry
I hurt her we broke up and I messed up
by kissing Nessa this is the best part I
am not sorry - Josh we are not boys
and we haven't boy Josh ended haven't
been boys since he lied to Charlie
saying I had an STD six months ago
trying to get her to stop seeing I'm not
going to let these hypocrites try and
ruin my life without their lives being
out on the Internet - wrote to try to
sabotage someone's relationship so just
go something be like 8 you know he has
herpes right yeah yeah what yeah he's
got he's got the herp
yeah not knowing don't like isn't it
like 1 in 4 people have [ __ ] herpes
or some [ __ ]
is this like everyone's born with herpes
isn't that the stat everyone has herpes
I have it probably yeah you know it's
just yeah it's hilarious like they don't
hit the irony would be like at the dude
who said that you know if Josh
ironically had you know if he was born
with genital herpes yeah and he's
sitting there saying like you know what
he got an STD it's like bro yeah you
have an SD he's ok but I was born with
it so it's fine
it's nothing really yeah yeah so funny
to get dumped over an STD man I think
it's funny I mean it's not funny that
that happens to be all because they have
like legit STDs and that's [ __ ] up
this whole Damon is saying I think it's
funny to air out
is this part of the story publicly like
yes such a weird little detail that you
shouldn't even you shouldn't even bring
up the rumor ever that that someone else
said you have an ST because then there's
gonna be people that just believe that
and I just want to set the record
straight for no one that knew I most
definitely do not have an STD I yield my
time that people are gonna be like oh
okay so you do yeah so again um
$1,000,000 one coin package to anyone
who can corroborate a little hoodies STD
yeah yeah let us know bro sending me
that that's it that's been pretty smart
I'd say 1 million bucks and one coin
could be worth I mean it could be worth
a billion yeah five years in five days
actually yeah in about five to five in
about five hours of I've by the time you
hear this your opportunity is probably
missed already so yeah exactly so
you